[Musique]
où
non
[Musique]
ans
m
bonjour à tous merci beaucoup je
m'appelle martin j'aurais dean j'ai 27
ans j'ai commencé la musique à 6 ans a
fait 21 ans que je fais du piano je suis
passionné j'ai fait huit ans d'études
chambre quatrième disque en décembre
j'étudie à jazz à tours au conservatoire
de paris au conservatoire d'amsterdam où
j'ai eu mon bachelor et 1 philadelphie
aux états unis attend peu l'université
où j'ai eu mon pasteur de grille
la star de glee et je suis pas là pour
vous parler de moi je suis là pour vous
parler d'un thème qui me tient à coeur
c'est le jazz la musique de jazz dont je
suis passionné voilà donc ces partis le
jazz c'est quoi ces de musique jeune
moderne actuelle ok c'est une musique
qui est qui a à peu près cent deux ans
vu qu'elle est née approximativement en
donc on fait le calcul 102 en 2019 on
pourrait faire le parallèle avec la
musique classique elle est beaucoup plus
vieille mais le jazz n'est pas une
musique morte
le mot jazz c'est quoi en fait ça vient
d'où c'est déjà ça une connotation
sexuelle à la basse et c'est le plaisir
la danse le swing le désir le sexe voilà
c'est tout ça à la fois en fait alors
dans cette musique
il ya eu des courants novateur on peut
en citer quelques-uns
chronologiquement donc du plus ancien au
plus moderne
vous avez le blues à la base vous avez
le dixieland le new orleans le stride le
ragtime l'ère des pianos mécaniques le
swing le be bop le hard bop le cool
le free jazz le
jazz modal avec john coltrane et miles
davis le jazz fusion avec wiz en report
ou de jaco pastorius ou le m days avec
steve coleman et le jazz moderne celui
que je joue celui qu'on joue nous les
musiciens de jazz et d'ailleurs c'est
terriblement actuel parce
qu'actuellement il ya deux musiciens
christian scott avec streit miss ratched
musique et logan richarson avec urban à
qui crée de l'innovation aujourd'hui
donc je vous parlais de jazz de piano ok
mais je suis aussi là pour vous parler
d'innovation sociale but aussi un peu de
la conférence et donc quand on écrit un
morceau de jazz c'est tout à fait simple
il ya différentes règles qu'il faut
respecter
déjà il ya la composition en elle même
c'est l'art finalement de figer
l'improvisation l'improvisation c'est
l'art de composer en temps réel mais
donc vous se place l'innovation en tout
cela et c'est ce qu'on va voir
maintenant c'est tout simple en fait
quand j'avais 18 ans j'avais des
chaussures trouées j'étais un peu un
clodo j'avais mais mon manteau en cuir
et j'étais au crr de paris et au
conservatoire de paris j'ai vu un prof
qui s'appelle emilie panique est un
ancien pilote de ligne qui m'a dit un
jour martin c'est tout simple si tu veux
innover dans cette musique
il faut que tu puisses légèrement
modifier certaines règles distordre
certaines règles et ces trois règles
c'est le rythme l'harmonie et la mélodie
donc je vais vous illustrez maintenant
comment les musiciens actuels font pour
innover en 2019 en 2020
donc le rythme à l'époque on jouait plus
comme ça ça c'est un morceau thelonious
monk qui s'appelle à ce minot et ça fait
[Musique]
oh
maintenant quelqu'un comme ben wendel il
va penser la métrique donc le 4 4
plus tôt en 5,8 donc ça va donner
quelque chose comme ça
[Musique]
vous voyez une différence ça c'est tous
les courants c'est tout les toute
l'innovation
donc voila c'était reid dont vous avez
la mélodie la mélodie charlie parker
dans son seau d'eau na li c'était plus
des mélodies anguleuses du bebop par
exemple donc plus comme ça
[Musique]
il
où
etc etc et maintenant c'est plus des
choses comme ça
oh
[Musique]
et ses rites mélodie vous a capté
harmonie à l'harmonie si on prend à
corte witham de george gershwin
compositeur des années 1930 à 50 on
obtient quelque chose comme ça
harmoniquement donc les accords c'est
trois notes ensemble on obtient quelque
chose de ce type
[Musique]
m
on
[Musique]
où
e
[Musique]
ok maintenant c'est plus comme ça là
c'est une composition en moi ça
s'appelle heidi sur mon deuxième album
et ça donne ça
[Musique]
ces rythmes et mélodies harmonie mais ya
pas que ça moi je me réfère à des
philosophes
actuellement et depuis cinq ans et je
pense à schopenhauer un philosophe
allemand ou encore 1 01 euro
scientifique qui s'appelle idrissa
berkane qui a publié un bouquin qui
s'appelle libérer votre cerveau et la
révolution de la connaissance qui eux
disent que en gros toute révolution
passe par trois phases évident dangereux
et et pardon de ridicule dangereux
évident je vais arriver excusez moi
c'est la pression c'est adx moi je pense
pas je pense qu'on a c'est jamais à
l'artiste en lui même de dire si son
morceau si son courant et novateur c'est
plus autant au public aux gens qui
disent que voilà la marque dans
l'histoire était novatrice ou pas le
courant a été novateur ou pas c'est
quelque chose qui se fait sur le sur
beaucoup de temps donc c'est le jazz
c'est quoi c'est un langage universel
celui du son c'est une tradition commune
celle du partage c'est une musique qui
rassemble les gens auxquels peu importe
la couleur de peau d'où on vient où on
va c'est quelque chose qui unifie ayez
la transmission la transmission elle et
elle était orale avant dans les jazz
club dans les airs dans la rue et
maintenant elle est plus dans les
conservatoires vous voyez avec les
écoles on a la chance d'avoir des écoles
étaient département jazz c'est super
d'ailleurs et c'est très bon pour la
santé d'improviser donc si vous avez des
enfants ou si vous voulez vous même
improvisé faite le c'est très bon pour
la santé pour le moral et en plus ça ça
vous libère du stress et ça vous
ça au niveau du cerveau vous avez des
zones inactive qui sont actifs grâce à
ça donc fait le c'est bon pour la santé
et voilà je vous remercie à tous d'être
venus à ce stade x je vais terminer
cette conférence avec un morceau qui
s'appelle him for freedom l'hymne pour
la liberté que j'ai composé la semaine
dernière avec avant un concert parisien
dans le 11e arrondissement et donc c'est
un hymne pour les libertés mais pour nos
libertés
voilà je vous remercie de m'avoir écouté
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
mon
[Musique]
mon nez
m
[Musique]
ans
on
en
[Musique]
à
de même
[Musique]
non